Est-ce que vous avez déjà eu cette sensation étrange quand vous êtes dans un train à la gare
que le train d'à côté
se met à bouger
mais qu'en fait vous ne savez pas vraiment si c'est
ce train ou le vôtre qui vient de démarrer ?
Si vous avez déjà ressenti ça vous avez tout ce qu'il faut pour comprendre la théorie de la relativité restreinte
la théorie de la relativité vous le savez
on l'associe principalement à Einstein
mais il faut savoir que le principe de relativité est en fait beaucoup plus ancien
et que plusieurs des idées importantes
datent de l'époque de Galilée
dans la première moitié
du XVIIe siècle
en exagérant un peu on pourrait dire qu'Einstein s'est contenté de reprendre les idées de Galilée
et de faire une petite modification
dans une formule
mais une modification
qui sera lourde de conséquences
pour bien comprendre tout ça on va donc commencer par la théorie de la relativité galiléenne
or du temps de Galilée il n'y avait pas de train pour ressentir cette sensation bizarre dont j'ai parlé au début
mais on imaginait à peu près
la même chose avec des bateaux
supposez que vous ayez un grand mât
d'une certaine hauteur planté sur la plage
et que vous lanciez une pierre
du sommet de ce mât
en connaissant
l'angle et la vitesse
et là la pierre
va retomber au sol
au bout d'un certain temps
et à une certaine distance de la base du mât
ok bon maintenant imaginons que vous fassiez
exactement la même expérience
sur un bateau
qui navigue sur une mer calme
en ligne droite et à vitesse constante
et bien si vous lancez la pierre du sommet du mât de la même manière que sur la plage
le résultat sera exactement le même
c'est-à-dire que la pierre va toucher le pont
du bateau à la même distance de la base du mât
et avec le même temps de chute
quand on s'amuse
à lancer des objets
qu'on le fasse
sur la plage ou bien sur
un bateau qui se déplace en ligne droite à vitesse constante le résultat est le même
et Galilée nous propose de pousser le bouchon plus loin
en imaginant
tout un tas d'autres expériences
supposez que vous soyez enfermé dans un laboratoire sans fenêtre
avec à votre disposition des billes, des ressorts, des liquides, des aimants, des projectiles, des élastiques, tout ce que vous voulez
vous pouvez bien concevoir
n'importe quelle expérience
que votre laboratoire soit situé sur la plage
ou à l'intérieur d'un bateau
qui se déplace à vitesse constante
vous aurez exactement
les mêmes résultats
et donc si on vous a enfermé dans un laboratoire de ce genre
vous n'avez aucun moyen de déterminer
si vous êtes en mouvement sur le bateau
ou bien immobile sur la plage
et c'est exactement pour la même raison que vous avez cette sensation bizarre dans le train
s'il avance sans accélération et sans à-coups
aucun moyen de ressentir s'il bouge vraiment ou bien s'il est immobile
il y a une formule attribuée à Galilée
et qui résume bien ça
le mouvement et comme rien
c'est à dire que du point de vue
de la physique
il n'y a aucune différence
entre le fait d'être immobile
et le fait d'avancer en ligne droite
à vitesse constante
ce qu'on appelle
en mouvement rectiligne uniforme
et s'il n'y a aucune différence c'est qu'en fait ces notions n'ont pas de sens absolu
et c'est là la première clé
la vitesse n'est que relative
on parle toujours de vitesse
par rapport à quelque chose
pareil quand je dis immobile hein on doit toujours préciser immobile par rapport à quoi
et on peut pas dire d'un objet qui serait immobile dans l'absolu
alors ça nous paraît contre-intuitif hein parce qu'on vit sur terre et qu'on a en permanence le sol sous nos pieds
donc on a l'impression que si moi je suis sur la plage et vous dans le bateau
bah je suis quand même un peu plus immobile que vous
mais en fait non pas du tout
d'ailleurs vous savez certainement que même avachi dans votre canapé vous n'êtes pas du tout immobile hein
par exemple vous vous déplacez à cent mille kilomètres heure par rapport au soleil
Pour bien comprendre que les vitesses
ont un sens relatif
reprenons l'expérience des bateaux
mais cette fois avec des vaisseaux spatiaux
imaginez un coin de l'espace vide
loin de tout de galaxies
et deux vaisseaux en mouvement rectiligne uniforme l'un par rapport à l'autre
avec dans chaque vaisseau le même laboratoire
quelles que soient les expériences que l'on fasse
les résultats seront les mêmes dans les deux vaisseaux
et donc on n'a aucun moyen objectif
de faire une distinction entre les deux
le capitaine du vaisseau 1 s'il regarde par le hublot aura l'impression d'être immobile
et que c'est le vaisseau 2 qui vient vers lui
mais le capitaine du vaisseau 2 aura exactement la sensation inverse
et en fait y en a pas un qui a plus raison que l'autre hein
il n'y a aucun moyen de décider que l'un serait plus en mouvement ou plus immobile que l'autre
pour bien comprendre à quel point cette
idée peut paraître contre intuitive on va prendre quelque chose que l'on entend souvent
au sujet de la relativité restreinte dont on va parler tout à l'heure
on lit parfois
des affirmations du genre
quand on va à une vitesse proche
de celle de la lumière
on vieillit moins
mais non juste dit comme ça,
ça peut pas être vrai
la notion de vitesse elle est relative pas absolue
donc dire aller à une vitesse proche de celle de la lumière tout court
ça n'a pas de sens
là moi en ce moment si vous voulez je vais à 280 mille kilomètres par seconde
si un vaisseau passe près de moi à cette vitesse-là
de son point de vue à lui
il est immobile et je me déplace à cette vitesse
le mouvement et comme rien
il faut vraiment abandonner cette idée
que la vitesse serait absolue
cela devrait être jouable mais c'est vraiment important
parce que ça n'est que le début
ok donc à ce stade résumons ce que nous dit Galilée
et qui forment donc le principe de relativité galiléenne
si vous avez deux laboratoires qui se déplace en mouvement rectiligne uniforme l'un par rapport à l'autre
qu'il s'agisse de train de bateaux ou de vaisseaux spatiaux
les résultats des expériences seront toujours les mêmes
et donc il n'existe aucun moyen de les distinguer et de définir que l'un serait plus immobiles ou plus en mouvement que l'autre un point
tout de même avant d'avancer l'idée que les mouvements soit en ligne droite et à vitesse constante est vraiment essentiel
si on commence à mettre des accélérations des virages des rotations et bien ça ne marche plus
par exemple si vous avez un bateau qui fait des ronds serré dans l'eau
même dans votre laboratoire sans fenêtre vous pouvez le distinguer de celui de la plage
posez une bille sur le sol elle restera immobile sur la plage
mais elle sera mise en mouvement
par la force centrifuge dans le bateau
donc il existe un moyen absolue
de distinguer ce bateau
j'espère qu'à ce stade de la vidéo
ces concepts vous parlent
et on va continuer encore un petit peu
avec Galilée parce qu'une fois qu'on
l'aura bien approfondie vous allez voir Einstein ce sera du gâteau
mais pour ça je vais devoir introduire un peu de formalisme
et quelques gros mots dont j'ai évité de parler jusqu'ici comme par exemple l'idée
de référentiels
La première chose à noter c'est que pour parler de ce qui se passe dans nos expériences
on a besoin de l'espace et du temps
et on va même tout de suite les combiner pour former l'espace-temps
ce qu'on va appeler un événement
c'est un point de l'espace temps
c'est à dire quelque chose
qui se passe à un endroit précis de l'espace
à un instant précis
un événement ça peut être par exemple l'impact de la bille sur le pont du bateau
ou la collision entre deux objets ou une explosion, etc.
tout ce qui se produit en un point précis de l'espace-temps est un événement
un truc important quand on fait des expériences ou des calculs
c'est de pouvoir mettre
des coordonnées aux événements
c'est à dire qu'on veut pouvoir leur attribuer avec des chiffres
une position précise
dans l'espace
et un instant précis
dans le temps
on veut pouvoir dire la bille a touché le sol
à tel endroit et à tel moment
les coordonnées d'un événement ça prend généralement une forme x y z pour l'espace
et t pour le temps
et donc un référentiel c'est simplement quelque chose qui permet d'attribuer des coordonnées aux événements dans l'espace et dans le temps
alors généralement on présente ça avec des grilles par exemple si je trace une grille sur la plage avec une échelle de longueur
ça permet de dire exactement où est tombé ma bille
mais une grille ça suffit pas il faut aussi une horloge
qui permettent de dire à quel moment s'est produit l'impact
en fait idéalement un référentiel ce serait une sorte de grille géante en 3d
avec des horloges en chaque point de la grille
et qui permettent dès qu'un événement a lieu quelque part
de lui attribuer des coordonnées
d'espace et de temps
alors voyez bien que cette idée
c'est une vue de l'esprit hein
en pratique on se trimbale pas avec des grilles géantes sur lequel seraient fixées des milliers d'horloge
mais l'important pour avoir un référentiel
c'est d'avoir une procédure
qui permette de faire tout comme
dans mon exemple du bateau le type sur la plage a son référentiel et celui sur le bateau a le sien
et ils sont différents
si je prends un événement donné par exemple l'explosion d'une fusée de feu d'artifice
on pourrait attribuer à cet événement certaines coordonnées dans le référentiel de la plage et d'autres coordonnées dans le référentiel du bateau
évidemment ce qui fait toute la subtilité de l'affaire c'est qu'un référentiel peu bouger par rapport à un autre
ici le point de coordonnées spatiales
000 du bateau par exemple la base du mât
ne va pas toujours être présentées par les mêmes coordonnées dans le référentiel de la plage
puisque vue de la plage il bouge au cours du temps
bon maintenant qu'on est armé de cette notion de référentiels reprenons ce que nous dit Galilée
il nous dit que si je fais la même expérience
sur le bateau et sur la plage je vais avoir le même résultat
mais ça veut dire quoi exactement la même expérience et le même résultat
eh bien ça veut dire les mêmes chiffres
pris chacun dans son référentiel
par exemple je lance la vie avec un angle de 30 degrés à deux mètres par seconde d'une hauteur de 10 mètres
tous à mesurer dans le référentiel de la plage
et pour reproduire l'expérience dans le bateau je me mets dans son référentiel et j'utilise les mêmes valeurs une hauteur de dix mètres
30 degrés et une vitesse de 2 mètres par seconde dans le référentiel du bateau
et quand je dis que le résultat sera le même
c'est que si la première bille tombe à deux mètres de la base du mât dans le référentiel de la plage et bien la seconde
tombera à deux mètres dans le référentiel du bateau
et grâce à cette idée on peut donner un sens un petit peu plus générale à la relativité selon Galilée
si les résultats des expériences sont les mêmes
c'est à dire que les lois de la physique sont les mêmes dans les deux référentiels
les lois de la physique
ah oui généralement quand on fait de la physique on utilise des équations
idéalement une équation nous permet de prédire le résultat d'une expérience
on peut représenter ça comme une petite machine on lui donne en entrée les conditions de l'expérience
telle position telle vitesse etc
elle nous file en sortie le résultat par exemple la bille est tombé à tel endroit
ce qu'implique le principe de relativité c'est que les lois de la physique les équations à utiliser pour prédire les résultats d'expériences
doivent être les mêmes dans deux référentiels en mouvement rectiligne uniforme l'un par rapport à l'autre
si vous êtes sur la plage et que vous avez trouvé les bonnes équations pour prédire le mouvement de la bille bah vous pouvez les
filer à votre pôte qui est sur le bateau il pourra les utiliser et ça va fonctionner c'est une manière de formuler le principe de
relativité qui peut vous paraître un petit peu abstraite mais on va voir qu'elle joue un rôle important
ok donc je vous expliquais qu'on pouvait utiliser
plusieurs référentiels que chacun pouvait
faire ses petites expériences dans son coin
et pour l'instant ce sont un peu
comme deux mondes qui s'ignorent
mais si quelqu'un s'amuse à lancer une bille depuis le mât du bateau qu'est ce qui nous empêche d'analyser cette expérience depuis la plage
concrètement le fait que la bille touche le pont du bateau est un événement
dont on a les coordonnées dans le référentiel du bateau
et on peut se demander quels sont les coordonnées de ce même événement dans le référentiel de la plage
de manière plus générale si je connais les coordonnées x y z t d'un événement dans un référentiel
comment je peux les calculer dans un autre référentiel
bon pour commencer il y a un cas simple c'est quand les deux référentiels sont fixes l'un par rapport à l'autre
par exemple je peux choisir un certain référentiel sur la plage
et vous vous décidez d'en prendre un autre qui est simplement décalée
pour passer des coordonnées d'un événement du premier référentiel vers le deuxième il
suffit d'ajouter le décalage rien de très compliqué
on dit qu'on applique une translation
autre possibilité on est tous les deux sur la plage mais mon référentiel est simplement tourné par rapport aux autres il faut faire un peu
de géométrie mais là non plus pas de grosses difficultés si on a un même événement
on passe sans problème de ses coordonnées dans le
premier référentiel à ses coordonnés dans le deuxième on dit qu'on applique une rotation
voyons maintenant le cas le plus intéressant celui de deux référentiels en mouvement rectiligne uniforme l'un par rapport à l'autre
imaginons qu'on soit au même point de la plage à l'instant 0
mais que je me mette à avancer en ligne droite à disons 2 m par seconde
si un événement surgit
à trois mètres devant vous
au bout de cinq secondes
et bien moi entre temps j'aurais parcouru 10 mètres
et donc dans mon référentiel à moi il sera sept mètres derrière moi
allez on peut même mettre tout ça en formule
si un référentiel se déplace à vitesse U par rapport à un autre
on passe de la coordonnées x dans le premier référentiel à la coordonnée x' dans le second référentiel
avec la formule x' = x - Ut
c'est à dire qu'on retranche
la distance parcourue pendant le temps t
si les formules vous soulent retenez juste qu'il existe un moyen de passer des coordonnées d'un référentiel dans un autre
qui n'est pas très compliqué
et qu'on appelle ça
la transformation de Galilée
il y a quand même un truc que j'ai légèrement passés sous silence pour l'instant c'est la question du temps
je vous ai expliqué comment passer des coordonnées d'espaces d'un référentiel vers un autre
mais le temps c'est aussi une des quatre coordonnées d'un événement
et bien c'est simple le temps dans deux référentiels et toujours le même par
exemple sur la plage et sur le bateau
t' = t
en fait la seule chose qu'on s'autorise c'est un décalage c'est à dire que chacun peut prendre l'origine du temps où ça lui chante
c'est un peu comme avec les calendriers vous savez chacun peut choisir leur 0 où ça lui fait plaisir
mais à la fin on utilise tous la même année comme mesure de durée
bref au final j'ai un moyen de changer de référentiel
c'est à dire j'ai une opération mathématique
qui me permet de calculer les coordonnées d'espace-temps d'un événement dans un référentiel si je les connais dans un autre et bien maintenant
explorons les conséquences de cette transformation de Galilée
Si je suis dans le bateau et que je marche à deux mètres par seconde sur le pont au bout d'une seconde
je serais passée à la position x' = 2 m ok
imaginons maintenant que le bateau se déplace à dix mètres par seconde par rapport à la plage
et regardons ce même déplacement
vue de la plage je dois faire un changement de référentiel
je considère les deux événements je démarre et je m'arrête
j'ai leurs coordonnées dans le référentiel du bateau
et je calcule leurs coordonnées dans le référentiel de la plage en appliquant la transformation Galilée
alors ici c'est facile au bout d'une seconde
ben j'aurais parcouru dans le référentiel de la plage non pas deux mètres mais 12 m
tout ça est parfaitement naturel si j'avance à deux mètres par seconde sur le pont du bateau
et que le bateau se déplace à dix mètres par seconde
ben vue de la plage je me déplace à 12 mètres par seconde c'est à dire que les vitesses
s'ajoute alors ça vous paraît peut-être complètement naturel mais notez que pour bien faire ce raisonnement
on a dû passer des coordonnées dans le référentiel du bateau aux coordonnées dans le référentiel de la plage et donc
utiliser la transformation de Galilée
le fait que les vitesses s'ajoute ce qu'on appelle la loi de composition des vitesses
ça se déduit donc de la transformation Galilée
voyons maintenant d'autres conséquences de cette transformation même si vous allez peut-être les trouver un peu évidente
imaginons que je sois sur la plage avec un bâton qui mesure 1 m
c'est à dire que ses extrémités a et b
ont dans le référentiel de la plage
des coordonnées qui sont séparés d'un mètre
je peux aussi calculer les coordonnées de ces deux points dans le référentiel du bateau
alors pour ça je change de
référentiels grâce à la transformation de Galilée
et je trouve des coordonnées
qui sont évidemment différentes
hein et qui en plus change au cours du
temps par contre si je calcule l'écart entre ces deux coordonné c'est à dire la longueur du bâton
vu depuis le référentiel du bateau
c'est toujours la même un m
la longueur du bâton est la même quand on la mesure dans les deux référentiels
et plus généralement c'est pas seulement vrai de la longueur d'un objet physique
mais même la distance qui sépare deux événements est un truc absolue pas relatif ça dépend pas du référentiel
alors ça vous paraît peut-être normal mais d'un autre côté on a vu que les vitesses sont relatives pas absolue
donc c'est assez rassurant de se dire que les distances elles le sont
et puis notez quand même que pour arriver à ce résultat on a dû passer par la transformation Galilée
on a un terme technique pour ce genre de choses on dit que les distances sont des invariants elles sont laissées inchangées
par application d'une transformation de Galilée
autres invariants vous l'avez peut être deviné ce sont les durées
si je mesure la durée écoulée entre deux événements par exemple deux coups frappés sur un tambour
je peut la mesurer dans n'importe quel référentiel je trouverais la même chose
une conséquence du fait que les durées sont un invariant c'est qu'on peut avoir une notion de simultanéité
si deux événements sont simultanés dans un référentiel c'est à dire qu'ils sont séparés par un intervalle de temps qui est zéro
et bien cette séparation sera toujours zéro dans n'importe quel référentiel
et donc les deux événements sont simultanés dans tous les référentiels
donc les distances sont invariantes
et les durées sont invariantes
souvent on combine
ces deux constatations
pour dire que dans la physique de Galilée
l'espace et le temps sont absolus
et une fois de plus tout ça vous paraît peut-être complètement
naturel et intuitif
mais retenez que d'un point de vue technique pour y arriver on a dû passer par la transformation de Galilée
allez encore un dernier petit point essentiel et on en aura terminé avec Galilée
je vous ai dit tout à l'heure que le fait que
les résultats d'expériences soient les mêmes dans deux référentiels en mouvement rectiligne uniforme l'un par rapport à l'autre
trahissait le fait que les lois de la physique devait être les mêmes
je vous rappelle d'un point de vue pratique ça veut dire que si vous avez des équations qui vous permettent de calculer ce qui
se passe dans une expérience
vous pouvez utiliser les mêmes équations dans un autre référentiel dans lequel vous auriez fait la même expérience
très bien mais pour l'instant j'ai absolument rien dit sur ce qu'étaient ces équations qui permettent de calculer les phénomènes
et ben le principe de relativité ne nous le dit pas
mais il y a une idée absolument fondamental à comprendre
c'est que le principe de relativité
limite fortement les possibilités
à cause de lui les équations ne peuvent pas être n'importe quoi
on va prendre un exemple
vous savez sans doute qu'une des lois qui régit le mouvement des objets c'est la fameuse loi de Newton
F = ma
c'est à dire que la masse fois l'accélération
est égale à la force ou à la somme des forces qui s'applique
cette loi elle a été proposée par Newton donc
mais seulement une cinquantaine d'années après le principe de relativité de Galilée
imaginons qu'à l'époque Newton
ait eu un copain on va l'appeler Neuton
qui lui voulait proposer une autre loi
F = mv
c'est à dire que la somme des forces est égale à la masse fois la vitesse
donc normalement pour savoir lequel des deux a raison entre Newton et Neuton
bas ont fait des expériences et on regarde laquelle des deux lois marche le mieux
sauf que là on peut disqualifier la proposition de Neuton
sans faire la moindre expérience
grâce au principe de relativité
ce principe nous dit que les lois doivent être les mêmes dans deux référentiels qui sont en mouvement rectiligne
uniforme l'un par rapport à l'autre
alors reprenons notre place et notre bateau
qui avance à disons 10 mètres par seconde
quelqu'un sur le pont du bateau fait une expérience avec une bille
mesure sa vitesse horizontale par exemple 5 mètres par seconde
et appliquent F=mv
donc F = m x 5
mai pour celui qui est sur la plage à cause de la composition des vitesses
la vitesse de la bille est
de 15 mètres par seconde
donc si le principe de relativité est vrai
il doit appliquer la même loi est f = mv
et lui va donc écrire
f = m x 15
et là on a un problème la somme des forces peut évidemment pas être égal à l'un et à l'autre
donc sans faire la moindre expérience rien qu'en la regardant
on peut savoir que la loi de Neuton ne peut pas marcher
parce qu'elle n'est pas compatible avec la transformation de Galilée
bon je vous laisse vous convaincre que la loi de Newton  F=ma elle elle est compatible
parce que l'accélération sera bien la même dans les deux référentiels
attention ça nous dit pas que la loi de Newton est forcément la bonne
ça nous dit juste que celle de Neuton elle est fausse à coup sûr
le principe de relativité impose des restrictions
forte sur les lois physiques possibles
il nous dit pas lesquels sont les bonnes mais il permet de faire un bon tri préliminaire et d'ailleurs cette idée de restreindre les lois
physiques possibles à partir de considérations qui sont en fait des considérations de symétrie elle est vraiment
essentiel parce que c'est sur elles que se font toute la physique théorique moderne qu'on parle de relativité restreinte de relativité générale
ou même de théorie quantique des champs bon donc avant d'attaquer la relativité restreinte
un dernier résumé de la situation
le principe de relativité galiléennes nous dit que dans des référentiels en mouvement rectiligne uniforme les uns par rapport aux autres
les résultats des expériences sont les mêmes les lois de la physique sont les mêmes qu'on change de référentiels en utilisant les transformations de Galilée
que la notion de vitesse est relative que les vitesses se compose en s'ajoutant simplement que les distances et les durées sont des invariants
que la simultanéité existe de façon absolue et que la loi de Newton F=ma fait partie des lois compatible
bien après tout ces préliminaires essentiel on va pouvoir rentrer dans le vif du sujet
Depuis la fin du xviie siècle et jusqu'au début du 20e le couple Galilée Newton a fonctionné parfaitement
et j'espère que vous avez bien maintenant en tête la distinction entre les deux
Galilée c'est pour le principe de relativité et Newton c'est pour la loi F=ma qui se trouve être
compatible avec la transformation de Galilée alors quand je dis que ça a fonctionné parfaitement c'est que par exemple on a pu utiliser ces équations
pour prédire le mouvement des planètes où la trajectoire des boulets de canon
mais à la fin du 19e siècle il ya une idée qui a commencé à émerger et qui collait pas avec ce tableau
c'est l'idée que la vitesse de la lumière serait la même dans tous les référentiels
alors pour bien comprendre ce que ça veut dire on va prendre un exemple classique et puis allez on va revenir au train
imaginons que je sois dans un tgv qui avance à 100 mètres par seconde et que vous soyez une vache qui regardent le train passer
si je lance une balle à dix mètres par seconde devant moi et bien pour vous là bas lire à
110 mètres par seconde sans plus 10 c'est la proposition des vitesses mais avec la lumière et bien ça ne marche plus
si je tire un rayon lumineux disons avec un laser
ce rayon gras pour moi qui suis dans le train à la vitesse de la lumière
environ 300 mille kilomètres par seconde soit 300 millions de mètres par seconde
on a envie de penser que pour vous ce rayon devrait aller à 300 millions + 100 mètres par seconde en ajoutant les vitesses
et bien non pour vous il ira aussi à 300 millions de m par seconde
ça paraît bizarre non
eh bien ça l'est encore plus si on commence à imaginer que le train errait à dison 200 mille kilomètres par seconde
et bien même s'il travaille à 200 mille kilomètres par seconde est que le rayon laser va trois cent mille kilomètres par seconde
vu du sol le rayon ira toujours à
300 mille kilomètres par seconde pas 500 milles la vitesse de la lumière est la même dans tous les référentiels
alors je vous affirme que ça comme si on avait vraiment fait l'expérience avec un train allant à 200 mille kilomètres par seconde
évidemment ça n'est pas le cas vous avez le droit de douter de ce que je vous raconte
ce qui a convaincu les physiciens de ça à l'époque c'est principalement deux choses un résultat d'expériences et une considération plus théorique
l'expérience c'est celle de michael sohn et morlaix
je vais pas là détaillé mais son but était de détecter des variations de la vitesse de la lumière
suivant l'orientation de la direction la lumière par rapport aux mouvements de la terre
si mikkelsen et morlaix avait détecté des changements ça aurait pu prouver l'existence d'un référentiel absolue dans lequel se serait déplacé la lumière
qu'on appelait les terres sauf que l'expérience n'a rien trouvé pas de variation de vitesse pas des terres
elle a donc confirmé l'idée que la vitesse de la lumière est bien la même dans tous les référentiels
l'autre raison de croire fermement cette idée bizarre venait d'une théorie les équations de l'électromagnétisme de james maxwell
à la fin du 19e siècle maxwell avait réussi le tour de force qui consiste à unifier
l'électricité le magnétisme et la lumière grâce à une série d'équations qui porte maintenant son nom
alors rassurez vous je vais pas détailler tous que ces symboles barbares signifie le seul truc important à savoir c'est que ces équations
implique aussi que la vitesse de la lumière soit la même dans tous les référentiels
bref au début du 20e siècle on avait un souci
d'un côté le principe de relativité et la transformation Galilée qui nous disent que les vitesses sont toujours relative et se compose en s'additionnant
et de l'autre les équations de maxwell et l'expérience de mikkelsen et morlaix qui nous disent que la vitesse de la lumière est la même
dans tous les référentiels
alors comment on s'en sort
et bien l'idée clé d'Einstein c'est de conserver le principe de relativité mais de remplacer la
transformation de Galilée on garde la notion que dans deux référentiels en mouvement rectiligne
uniforme les résultats d'expériences sont les mêmes les lois de la physique sont les mêmes et donc on peut parler distinguer mais on change la
formule qui permet de transformer les coordonnées d'un événement d'un référentiel à un autre et on la remplace par celle ci
on appelle ça la transformation de lawrence et dans cette formule c'est désigne la vitesse de la lumière
alors là vous demandez peut-être d'où sort cette formule habitable et ce qui a bien pu pousser
Einstein a proposé ça pour remplacer la transformation de Galilée qui était pourtant si simple
là vous vous souvenez que je vous ai dit que le principe de relativité imposé des restrictions sur les lois physiques possibles
et que par exemple la loi de Newton est f = ma était compatible avec la transformation Galilée mais pas la loi flm v
eh bien figurez vous qu'à l'époque on avait déjà remarqué que les équations de maxwell celle de l'électromagnétisme
n'était pas compatible avec la transformation Galilée
par contre poincaré avait montré qu'elle était compatible avec une variante la transformation de lawrence
est donc ce café Einstein c'est de suggérer que la bonne transformation à utiliser dans le principe de relativité
ça ne soit pas la transformation Galilée mais plutôt la transformation de lorraine
en exagérant à peine on pourrait dire que l'essence de la relativité c'est juste ce petit changement
sauf qu'on va voir que les conséquences sont énormes pour tout d'abord on a dit que le problème principal qu'on avait c'est
le fait que la vitesse de la lumière soit la même dans tous les référentiels
les a on peut vérifier si la transformation de lorraine se résout ce problème
quand on passe de la transformation de Galilée à celle de Lawrence la loi de coûts position des vitesses change
on passe de la simple addition qu'on a vu à un truc que plus compliquée
donc la première chose dont on peut s'assurer c'est que cette nouvelle formule permet effectivement
d'avoir une vitesse de la lumière qui soit identique dans tous les référentiels
si la vitesse v dans le premier référentiel et et gallas et la vitesse de la lumière
vous voyez que la vitesse dans le second référentiel sera automatiquement et gallas est également donc ça marche
évidemment le fait que ça fonctionne n'est pas non plus un hasard total
je vous ai dit que la transformation de lawrence c'étaient celles avec lesquelles sont compatibles les équations de maxwell
qui prédisent que la vitesse de la lumière est la même dans tous les référentiels donc tout ça est cohérent
bon donc pour la vitesse de la lumière c'est très bien sauf que c'est pas la seule chose qu'il faut vérifier
comme toujours en science quand on propose une nouvelle théorie il faut faire quand même un peu attention
on peut pas complètement cassé et rejeter ce qu'on avait avant et qui fonctionnait bien
or la transformation de Galilée l'addition des vitesses ça marchait quand même pas mal et donc un point très important c'est que contrairement aux apparences
la transformation de lorraine ce n'est pas si différente que ça que la transformation Galilée en
particulier quand la vitesse y eut entre les deux référentiels est faible par rapport à ses la vitesse de la lumière
est bien la transformation de lawrence et sa composition des vitesses
se réduisent à celle de Galilée il ya en particulier ce petit bout de formule ici qu'on appelle le facteur de lawrence
on note souvent gamma pour simplifier et quand la vitesse y est suffisamment faible disons inférieur à 1 100e de la vitesse de la lumière
eh bien il devient très très proche de 1
ce que nous dit Einstein au final c'est donc de garder le principe de relativité mais de remplacer la transformation Galilée par celle de lawrence
pour les vitesses faibles ça ne fait quasiment aucune différence
mais ça assure que la vitesse de la lumière sera bien la même dans tous les référentiels bref on a résolu la contradiction
avec tout de même un petit prix à payer c'est que vous avez vu les formules sont un chouïa plus compliqué hein
et puis il ya aussi quelques conséquences assez contre-intuitive dont il va falloir qu'on parle
On a vu tout à l'heure que la transformation de Galilée préserver les distances
si vous êtes sur la plage et moi sur le bateau
on attribuera des coordonnées différentes aux extrémités du navire mais on sera d'accord sur sa longueur la différence entre les deux coordonnées
et bien ça aussi bizarre que ça puisse paraître on le perd avec la transformation de leur ex
et ça devient manifeste surtout quand on commence à aller à des vitesses relative qui sont très épais
imaginons que le navire à une vitesse v
que dans son référentiel la poupe soit là coordonnées x égal zéro et la proue x égale elle
elle est donc la longueur du bateau dans son référentiel
vous pouvez appliquer la transformation de lawrence pour voir ce que deviennent ces coordonnées dans le référentiel de la plage et je vous épargne les
calculs mais vous allez trouver l
gamma vous souvenez un gamin c'est ce qu'on appelait le facteur de lawrence un truc qui vaut quasiment 1 quand la vitesse relative d'aidé au
référentiel est faible mais qui augmente quand on s'approche de la vitesse de la lumière
donc si mon bateau va à 10 ans ou même 1000 mètres par seconde
vue de la plage vous serez d'accord avec moi sur sa longueur mais silva disons à la moitié de la vitesse de la lumière
dans votre référentiel la longueur du bateau sera d'environ 15 % inférieure à celle dans mon référentiel
alors à ce stade il est vraiment important de bien comprendre ce que ce résultat veut dire
en relativité restreinte on entend parfois que la vitesse raccourci les objets
d'ailleurs on appelle ce phénomène la contraction des longueurs mais bon moi j'aime pas trop cette formulation parce que contrairement à ce qu'elle laisse penser
il n'y a pas de modifications physiques qui seraient induites par la vitesse
c'est juste qu'en relativité restreinte les notions de longues heures de distance sont relatives elles dépendent du référentiel de
l'observateur
alors ça paraît un peu dur à avaler au début mais d'un autre côté c'est ce qu'on a dû faire avec la vitesse dans la
relativité galiléennes
psychologiquement vous devriez être prêt
de même qu'il n'ya pas de sens a parlé de la vitesse d'un objet de façon absolue
eh bien il n'y a pas de sens non plus à parler de sa longueur ou plus généralement de la distance qui séparait deux événements
et bien sûr sans surprise ce que je viens de vous annoncer pour les distances on va se le taper aussi pour le temps et
les durées si on prend deux événements par exemple deux coups frappés sur un tambour qui serait situé sur le bateau
on peut prendre les coordonnées dans l'espace temps de ces deux événements dans le référentiel du bateau
et calculer ce que sont ses coordonnées dans le référentiel de la plage en appliquant la transformation de lawrence cette fois
ci dans le référentiel du bateau la durée qui sépare les deux coups étaient
et bien dans le référentiel de la pl ce sera gamma tu es toujours le fameux facteur de lawrence
comme tout à l'heure si la vitesse du bateau par rapport à la plage est faible devant la vitesse de la lumière
gama est quasiment 1 et donc dans les deux référentiels la durée et la mêmeté
mais si la vitesse du bateau s'approche de celle de la lumière
gama est plus grand que 1 et la durée mesuré dans le référentiel de la plage sera plus grande que celle mesurée depuis le bateau
on appelle parfois ce phénomène la dilatation du temps
mais même remarque que tout à l'heure c'est une formulation un peu trompeuse il faut bien comprendre ce que ça veut dire
juste quand relativité restreinte la notion de durée elle est relative s'avère qu'elle n'est plus la même pour tous les observateurs
et donc ça n'a pas de sens de parler de la durée qui séparait deux événements
alors à nouveau ce résultat peut vous paraître un peu difficile à avaler mais je vais vous en donner une illustration concrète
qui est quelque chose qu'on peut mesurer et qui confirme ses idées
à tout moment du jour et de la nuit des rayons cosmiques frappe la terre
lorsqu'on appelle rayons cosmiques ce sont en fait des particules par exemple des protons qui nous arrive à grande vitesse de l'espace
quand ses rayons pénètrent dans l'atmosphère il entre en collision avec les noyaux atomiques des molécules de l'air
ce qui provoque l'émission de tout un tas d'autres particules qui forment ce qu'on appelle une gerbe et parmi ces particules on trouve des murs
alors un million pour faire simple c'est une variante de l'électron avec quand même une petite différence essentielle c'est qu'un million et
instable il a une durée de vie moyenne d'environ 2 microsecondes
quand les muons sont créés dans la gerbe ils sont propulsés à une vitesse énorme
99 5 % de la vitesse de la lumière
alors naïvement à cette vitesse là et sachant qu'ils ont une durée de vie de deux micro secondes les muons devrait parcourir environ
600 mètres en moyenne avant de se désintégrer
ce qui est bizarre c'est qu'en pratique on observe que les murs sont capables de voyager sur des distances beaucoup plus importante de l'ordre de
plusieurs kilomètres comment on explique ça et bien justement par le fait que les notions de durée et de distances sont relatives
considérer les deux événements suivants la création du mur et sa désintégration
alors quand on dit que la durée de vie moyenne du mur et de deux micro secondes on parle de sa durée de vie
vue depuis son propre référentiel
maintenant si on regarde ces deux mêmes événements création et d intégration
mais dans le référentiel de la terre et qu'on calcule la durée qui les séparent
à cause de la dilatation du temps on va trouver une valeur plus élevée
comme le mur on est la terre sont en mouvement relatif à une vitesse de 99 5% de celle de la lumière
le fameux facteur de lawrence vaut environ 10
et la durée de vie moyenne du mur ont vu dans le référentiel de la terre et d'une vingtaine de microseconde
ce qui explique que de notre point de vue celui du référentiel de la terre
le mur on parcourt des distances beaucoup plus importante que ce qu'on avait naïvement calculé
je sais c'est totalement contre intuitif et le problème c'est que si on prend ces notions de dilatation du temps
contraction des longueurs sans faire un peu attention on se retrouve vite à raconter des bêtises pour ne pas se tromper c'est pas si compliqué
oublier cette histoire de temps qui se dilate et revenait à des notions
d'observation c'est à dire qu'ils mesurent quoi il faut bien identifier les événements dont on parle et chercher leurs coordonnées d'espace-temps dans les différents référentiels
et bien sûr se rentrer dans la tête cette notion de relativité
le fait qu'on a pas le droit de parler de la distance ou la durée comme si c'était un truc absolue
venons en maintenant à une autre conséquence de la relativité restreinte mais qui est reliés la perte de la notion de simultanéité
on a vu que dans la relativité de Galilée le temps est absolu et donc la notion de simultanéité l'est aussi
on peut prendre deux événements distincts dans l'espace par exemple le choc de deux billes
respectivement sur le pont du bateau et sur la plage et affirmer le cas échéant qu'ils sont simultanés
en relativité restreinte ça ne marche plus je vous ai pas les calculs mais on peut très bien avoir un référentiel
dans lequel ces deux événements auront des coordonnées temporelles différentes c'est à dire que dans ce référentiel
l'un des deux se produira avant et l'autre après en relativité restreinte la simultanéité devient
relative et c'est quelque chose d'assez perturbant par exemple en temps normal j'ai le droit de me demander
qu'est ce qui se passe en ce moment dans la pièce d'à côté
sauf que ce qu'on vient de dire c'est que la notion d' en ce moment elle n'a plus un sens absolu en relativité restreinte
elle devient d'ailleurs d'autant plus floue qu'on parle de deux lieux qui sont éloignés dans l'espace
entre ici et là que les à côtés ça va mais par exemple ça n'a aucun sens de se demander ce que
curiosity est en train de faire en ce moment ce petit robot est sûre Mars qu'en moyenne
200 millions de kilomètres de nous la lumière met d'ailleurs une dizaine de minutes pour y aller et ça correspond en quelque sorte un à
l'incertitude que l'on peut avoir sur la notion de simultanéité entre les deux référentiels
donc ce que curiosity est en train de faire en ce moment bah ça dépend pour qui
bon donc il est temps de résumer où nous en sommes avec la relativité restreinte telle qu'elle a été proposée par Einstein
et de bien faire la comparaison avec la relativité galiléennes en relativité restreinte
on conserve le principe de relativité l'idée que les référentiels en mouvement rectiligne
uniforme sont impossibles à distinguer que les résultats d'expériences ils sont les mêmes et que les lois de la physique
ils sont les mêmes mais pour
passer d'un référentiel à l'autre on remplace la transformation Galilée par celle de Lawrence du coup la vitesse de la lumière devient
absolue c'est un invariant identique dans tous les référentiels par contre les autres vitesses elles restent relatives
mais la loi de composition devient différente d'une simple addition
les distances et les durées ne sont plus absolues la simultanéité aussi devient relative
et enfin c'était notre point de départ les équations de maxwell font partie des équations
compatibles et du coup le sommes des forces égales ma de Newton il est plus compatible
et bien non il ne marche plus on est obligé de le remplacer par une variante qui ressemble beaucoup à un
sauf qu'au lieu d'utiliser des vecteurs on utilise des vecteurs d'espace-temps avec quatre composantes qu'on appelle des quadri vecteurs
et je vous ai parlé détails mais on s'en sort
donc à ce stade vous devriez avoir une bonne vue de ce qu'est la relativité restreinte
de comment elle se compare à la relativité galiléennes et de pourquoi elle a toutes ses conséquences
un peu contre intuitive pour finir et pour bien vous montrer comment approcher toutes ces bizarreries
je voudrais vous parler de ce qui est un peu l'exemple classique de la relativité restreinte
ce qu'on appelle le paradoxe des jumeaux alors là comment raconte l'histoire en général on prend deux jumeaux jumelles bien sûr
ayant par exemple le 30 ans
l'un reste sur terre et l'autre s'en va dans l'espace dans une fusée dont la vitesse par rapport à la terre et disons
85% la vitesse de la lumière
ce jumeau embarque une montre et un calendrier et il décide au bout de cinq ans de faire demi tour
il retourne sur terre et y met 50 plus à l'avenir son voyage a donc duré dix ans il a maintenant 40 ans
sauf que quand il atterrit surprise sur terre il s'écoule et non pas 10 ans mes 20 ans et son frère a maintenant 50 ans
alors cette histoire est pas du tout une fable c'est exactement ce qui est prédit par la relativité restreinte
et d'ailleurs on a pu le vérifier sur des temps plus
en utilisant non pas des jumeaux mais des horloges atomiques
ultra précises ce qui est bizarre dans ce résultat c'est qu'ils donnent vraiment l'impression que c'est la vitesse qui fait vieillir moins vite
alors j'ai beaucoup insisté là dessus à la notion de vitesse elle est relative donc ça peut pas être ça
ça peut pas être le fait d'aller à une vitesse proche de celle de la lumière qui explique que le jumeau dans la fusée vieilli
mois d'ailleurs pour bien le voir on peut essayer de renverser la situation
le jumeau qui restait sur terre du point de vue de celui qui est dans la fusée il s'éloigne aussi à une vitesse qui est
85 % de celle de la vitesse de la lumière
donc il devrait aussi vieillir moins vite on a l'impression que la situation des deux jumeaux est un peu symétrique
c'est là qu'il ya un paradoxe apparent mais qui se résout bien si on regarde les choses avec rigueur le premier jumeaux celui qui reste
sur terre ne subit aucune force on dit qu'il est inerte et donc en mouvement rectiligne uniforme tout du long
le second en revanche mais il doit faire demi-tour un moment donné donc il est pas un mouvement rectiligne
uniforme du début à la fin l'expérience en pratique il doit certainement subir une décélération plus une accélération
donc la situation des deux jumeaux en fait n'est pas symétrique
alors on peut analyser ça en regardant les trajectoires dans l'espace temps
si on se place d'un référentiel de la terre la trajectoire du premier jumeaux c'est de rester à la même coordonnées spatiales et d'avancer dans
le temps
la trajectoire du second en fait celle ci ils se déplacent plus il fait demi tour et revient
on voit donc que les deux trajectoires relie les mêmes points de l'espace temps les deux événements qui sont le décollage et l'atterrissage
mais en utilisant des trajectoires différentes
la trajectoire du premier jumeaux elle est inerte tout du long il est en mouvement rectiligne uniforme du début à la fin
mais ça n'est pas le cas de celle du second jumeau
de manière générale on peut montrer que de toutes les trajectoires qui relie deux points l'espace temps
c'est toujours celle qui est inerte dans laquelle le temps semble le plus long
est d'ailleurs on pourrait utiliser ce résultat pour expliquer un autre paradoxe des jumeaux c'est celui qui se produit en présence de fort champ gravitationnel
ce qui est un des ressorts narratifs du film
interstellar pour ceux qui l'ont vu mais pour bien expliquer tout ça il faudrait que je vous parle de relativité générale
et ça sera pour une prochaine vidéo
autres sujets reliés que je sortirai bientôt c'est le fameux e égal mc2 qui est effectivement lié à la relativité restreinte
mais ça demande un peu de temps pour être traitée correctement alors je vais faire une deuxième vidéo
si vous voulez des points de vue complémentaires sur la relativité restreinte vous pouvez aller voir les vidéos de science for all qui notamment des
terriens peu mieux que moi le formalisme et aussi d'y penser qui donne bien la perspective historique que moi j'ai carrément complètement escamoté
et enfin comme toujours pour les plus curieux j'ai écrit un billet de blog qui donne pas mal de précision et de compléments technique
merci d'avoir suivi la vidéo comme d'habitude n'hésitez pas à liker partagé m des pousses bleus la cloche
facebook et twitter pour des nouvelles de la chaîne et vous pouvez bien sûr me souvenir sur tipis et si vous aimez aussi la lecture
pour les jeter un oeil à mon livre qui s'appelle insoluble mais vrai voilà à bientôt